how do Executives decide which
screenwriters are going to come into
pitch yeah so this is where the who you
know Park kind of comes in right so
going back to Executives having to have
a mental Rolodex right so their
relationships with those agents or
managers are how people are allowed to
come into pitch or how a screenplay will
end up on your desk so if I'm a
screenwriter at home who has an idea
nine times out of ten because there's
always that one right but nine times out
of ten you're going to need some kind of
representation to get you through that
door and most of that is because you
don't want just anybody able to send
something out somewhere because then
legally it becomes an issue right so
executives are not allowed to read
things unless they requested them right
so sometimes it may be that that Network
or Studio already has an idea right they
already own the IP and they just need a
writer to come and write it so they may
put their feelers out to their agents
and manage your friends and say we need
this kind of writer who writes this kind
of thing and we want them to come in and
Pitch us their take on this idea right
so that happens sometimes if it's their
original idea the screenwriter's
original idea then it comes it comes
from the other way they go to the agent
or manager and they say hey I have this
idea that I think will be really good
for this studio or this prediction
production company or this network and
then now that agent or manager is going
to contact the executive and say hey
this is what we have over here is this
something you guys are looking for
interested in listening to etc etc and
then if the executive is like yeah come
on in and they'll set up the meeting
so a screenwriter should never try to
just blindly send their work not just
because it's a bad idea where they could
get their work stolen but also it
violates protocol yes yes yes exactly so
most networks and Studios don't have a
submission process the only way that you
can get it in there is if you know that
executive like that's your uncle's
cousin or whoever right and they say to
you yeah yeah send it over to me right
or because your agent or manager sent it
for you and that just helps with all of
the legalities if a studio or network
decides to read something nine times out
of ten they're going to send you some
paperwork to sign off first that says
we're not going to steal your idea don't
try to say we stole it right a lot of
writers don't feel comfortable signing
that right and so then if they don't
feel comfortable signing it then the
network or the studio is not going to
read it and the reason that they have
that and I'm not going to get into the
the vocabulary and the jargon of the of
the the legalese but it basically is
saying to them we read a million zillion
screenplays a day we guarantee you we've
read your idea before so if you see it
show up on the screen it does not mean
we stole your idea right we could have
already been working on an idea very
similar and so I was in a situation like
that before where I even believed that
they were going to take us to court for
copyright infringement because we were
asking people to come in to pitch we had
the idea right and we wanted them to
come in different people with different
ideas to come and Pitch their take on it
right and so we didn't choose whoever's
take but we did choose someone else's
now we have the idea so that means it
was easy for plenty of people to have
similar takes well one particular group
thought this is way too close to our
take so from their point of view we had
stolen their idea right now I don't know
how far it went because I don't have
anything to do with the litigation right
but that kind of thing happens and I
think you know especially lay people
which is why you need that agent or
manager or lawyer or someone to play
your go-between as lay people you are
thinking I have the most unique idea in
the world and no one has ever thought
about this before and I think I've given
this example here before where I was in
three different states talking to three
different people and two of them weren't
screenwriters and they all pitched the
same idea to me all in the same like
couple of weeks you know what I mean so
it's really hard to come with a with an
extremely unique idea and so because of
that you don't want to send your your
work out to anybody willy-nilly you know
what I mean because you just don't want
to put yourself in that position but
it's also seen as unprofessional
optional when you do it to these major
you know uh these major Studios and
networks Etc because you're showing that
you don't know what the process is right
so you need to be able to have someone
as your go-between to be able to get you
into the door
going back to when you started your job
um and you were sitting at this desk and
you were waiting for people to sort of
bring stuff to you how did you
eventually learn what the duties of the
job were and that oh okay now I have to
be self-generating right right so uh you
know how Issa Ray always says Network
across right instead of networking up
and what that means is the people at the
top don't have time for you but the
people who are in your same position do
right so there was another woman at the
time her name was Corrine Huggins and
she was in the same position as me but
for a different department but our desks
were right next to each other and she is
the one who said this is probably where
you should start someone who was in the
program with me in my cohort with me and
who understood what position I was in
and with the kindness of her heart she
was like hey this is probably what you
should be doing and anytime she got some
information she gave me that information
and so I was able to kind of start
building from there also I was given a
few things to do in the office that is
usually for the coordinator to do which
is the highest ranked assistant in the
in the office who usually you can go
from coordinator to Executive if that's
what you want to do and if there is a
position open for you to do so and I
appreciated those because even though it
was work for a coordinator I had never
been a coordinator before so that means
I got to learn a lot so I did a whole
lot of reporting right so I was the
person who knew every single thing that
was in development at my network because
I was the person who did the reports I
knew what the updates were for every
single uh project I knew where they were
in whatever phase of the process they
were I knew what executive was working
on working on each project also I worked
with each of the other senior more
senior anyway Executives than I on at
least one or two of their projects so I
was able to and I was giving notes on
everything so even though I wasn't the
person who was going in to physically be
on the phone to give the notes I was
also giving notes on all of the projects
that were coming through so I got to
kind of be in every room all the time we
had one executive come in who
came from being a producer and being a
producer and kind of being independent
is a little bit different from being a
suit at the on the executive level and
the executives are the closest thing
that Hollywood's going to get to a suit
outside of like your agents and managers
and lawyers who are always you know
going to be pretty pulled up but you
know executives are like the next wrong
of that and so it's very corporate
because a lot of these Studios and
networks are owned by larger you know
corporations so it can get very
corporate which is different for a
producer and so this particular producer
gave me a lot of his responsibilities
because he was like this is just not how
I do think so here you do it which is
the best learning curve for me right
just give it to me just let me do it and
I'm gonna figure it out so once he gave
it to me and allowed me to just get in
there and get my feet wet it was fine
because I was able to learn as I was
going but as far as like me
understanding where to start in the
first place I didn't know I just did not
know
how fearful were people
networking across of losing their jobs
or feeling like maybe you might get the
upper hand so they didn't give you
information yeah um I actually only had
that in maybe two
um two uh situations for the most part
people were open I also don't think you
know if any of them decide to watch this
video they're probably going to be
surprised that I didn't know what I was
doing you know what I mean because the
couple of things that I was told to do I
also was the person who was in charge of
all of the diversity reports for all of
cable television so I was doing a lot I
just wasn't doing executive work because
I needed to be you know assigned to that
and once I was assigned to it then I had
something to do but as far as not
knowing that I should be out here having
lunches with people and getting to know
people like that's the part I didn't
know once people started giving giving
me assignments I started saying hey
here's the script read it I got that I
know how to do that here here are the
dailies give us notes cool I can do that
but as far as like day one hey here's
your desk just go didn't know it all so
I'd say for the most part there was no
competition that way
um especially like for example with uh
with Corrine we were in the same
position and she was in a different
department so there was no way that I
was going to come you know one up and
and take her job she you know Rose to
the Rose to the top of the ranks that
she should but there were a couple of
other people who
um felt like I might be competition and
I think that's just from a for whatever
reason women are taught that I don't
know why we get into a space and we feel
like only one of us can be here I have
no idea
um for me I was so busy trying to learn
and trying to figure out what was going
on that I wasn't thinking about anyone's
job I wasn't even thinking about being
promoted you know in in Hollywood people
can get promoted very easily they can
spend six months in a job title and move
to the next one and for me it was have
you even done that one long enough to
really know what goes on in the next one
just because I just didn't really
understand how the business worked that
way so for me I was more afraid that
someone was going to try to promote me
before I was prepared to be promoted I
wasn't thinking about anyone else's job
but for other people it was I don't know
I won't say anyone kept any information
for me I don't have evidence of that but
I do believe that there were some people
who felt threatened but that's because
they felt threatened period maybe it was
me being me but I think no matter who
would have been in my position you know
what I mean no matter who that person
was they may have thought this is a
person who can come and take my job and
for me that was the last thing on my
mind I was trying to figure out how to
do my own job you know
and just quickly is there any advice for
new people who are coming from another
state and they are taking on a similar
position or something within the
industry
any just little Common Sense things even
just maybe just observe and and don't
speak too much I don't know yeah you
know it's weird it's really just depends
on the environment of that office
um you know one of the things that
happened to me was on my first day I was
told be seen not heard
that crushed me because I'm the kind of
person who has to learn by doing you
know what I mean so if I can't ask
questions or at least that's what I
heard them say right if I can't ask
questions if I can't use my voice I
might as well not be here so that made
me sink into myself which was another
reason why it took me so long to figure
out what's my place here because I
didn't feel like I had anyone I could
ask right
whereas some of the other people who
were in my cohort were in places where
they had people who were open to be able
to say yeah if you have questions come
on and ask or if we're in a meeting and
you want to add something you can add it
meanwhile I don't know if everyone knew
that I was told to be seen and not heard
but that put me in a place of well I'm
not going to say like it's not I'm not
supposed to say anything should I be
saying something right and you never
want anyone who works with you for you
under You by on the side of you to feel
like their voice doesn't matter and
that's how I felt so not only am I
dealing with the fact that I'm new to
this and I came into this program
expecting to learn to be taught and
realizing that well actually it's not a
program it's a job so you're just
supposed to hit the ground running so
that was already you know a punch in the
face here I am in a brick wall but I was
also told we've seen not heard well if I
don't know what I'm doing and I can't
ask any questions what am I supposed to
do and so it took me a little while to
get over that
um maybe if I you know what this is all
also a thing about possibly being a
woman you know possibly being young I
was 26 or something like that you know I
didn't know if this was a go to HR kind
of thing you know what I mean I didn't
know if I was supposed to tattle on
people you know what I'm saying I didn't
know if I was supposed to be you know
saying something to somebody so that I
could be getting more
um so that's why I was so thankful that
Corrine was there to be able to say hey
do this try this why don't you try this
out and so I think you just have to you
have to figure out your environment you
have to figure out if there are people
who are open because there were other
people who were open who I could go to
and ask questions to but I need to
figure out what questions to ask this
was also during a time where YouTube
was decently new you know what I mean so
it's not like there were Executives on
YouTube talking about what it was to be
an executive like I said I didn't even
know what development was and if I typed
in development everything but
screenwriting came up everything but
Hollywood came up you know so as far as
figuring out where my other resources
were I felt like I was at a standstill
maybe there was a place that I could
have gone and I just didn't know it
existed but nowadays there's way too
much information out there for you right
like there are places where you can find
information about what your job title is
or your job role is or what you should
be doing or where you should be starting
um but if you can't find that in
external resources then find someone who
is there who has done that job before
who um you know who can be your Mentor
that you can have someone who you can
ask questions of because how are you
going to learn if you can't ask and I
love what you said earlier you said you
know each office is different and so
sometimes it's just knowing what these
unspoken rules are yeah that takes time
yeah it takes a lot of time to learn and
and in Hollywood because there's so much
ego because there's so much money and
there's so much hierarchy Etc it's
really something you gotta figure out is
this a place where I can walk in man or
woman young or old is this a place I can
walk in and just start talking you know
what I mean or is this a place where I
need to just kind of sit back figure out
what my my place is here and you know
and then execute after that but you know
figuring out if a room is going to be
welcoming or not it's the same thing if
you get on a writing staff if you are an
art of writing staff and you are the
staff writer there are a lot of rooms
that don't expect you to say anything
they expect you to just be there you
know what I mean then you get in a
different room and that show runner is
welcoming and they want to hear your
perspective and they want to know what
you have to say so you have to figure
out you know who are the people uh who
are your managers right and what kind of
environment are they setting for you and
figure out how to play in that and then
if that's not something that you want to
play in then start figuring out your
exit strategy so you can go play
somewhere else you know and there's a
there's a gracefulness to certain exits
as well you talked about HR and I know
it seems like things have changed people
go to HR now over something and there
can be ramifications for being that
person as well yeah so it's like a
really fine line do you want to say
something exactly do you not want to but
you know there can be ways to exit
situations gracefully and um you know I
haven't always been the best at that and
and I know I'm sure other people haven't
either and and it can really follow you
um and it's one of the reasons that I I
left the business it's one of the
reasons uh so I've told this story
before but I left the business so that I
could go do musical theater and uh dance
companies right which was always a dream
of mine but at this age you know I'm
thinking I'm in my career that dream is
gone right so that dream kind of came
back around at a moment of transition
for me anyway I felt like I had learned
everything that I needed to learn from
this particular place
and I wanted to then take those skills
somewhere else because I didn't feel
comfortable at this place and even
though I was 26 and had been told to be
seen and not heard
I didn't feel like I needed to go in and
make declarations about what I was
feeling you know I was born in the 80s
your feelings stay at home you know what
I mean you don't come into your job
talking about how people are making you
feel who cares get the job done if you
don't want to be here go somewhere else
right so I was in a place of deciding to
go somewhere else
um and then then this whole opportunity
to do something different came up and I
did it but when I came back I also came
back at
36 or seven right so it's a Whole Decade
later I'm a totally different woman I'm
far more confident than I was and that's
one of the reasons when I came back I
knew that I wanted to be at a place that
needed me a place that was going to hear
my voice a place that was going to
respect what I had to give I did not
want to be receiving a paycheck to just
be a number in the room you know what I
mean like I have things to offer so if
you're going to hire me then you're
going to get those things and now I'm
not walking into a room looking for
permission to speak I'm here because you
should want to hear my voice if not why
are you paying me why am I here right
but that's different because I have
these Decades of experience now so I
walk into a room totally differently but
at 26 I would I don't even know if I
thought about going to HR I don't even
know if I considered it now I can look
back and go well if I had I might have
started a problem right because I know
about the history and how it was 20
years ago you know
um but at this age I would probably talk
to HR because I believe in protocol so I
believe that you have to inform people
of something so that they can have an
opportunity to try to fix it because if
you don't inform them of it you just
keep it inside then you're going to come
to work frustrated every day and no one
else is going to know why you're
frustrated because they don't know you
have a problem so either you speak to
your supervisor about your problem if
you can't speak to them you go to the
person above them if you can't speak to
them you talk to HR whoever it is that
you're supposed to talk to to try to
solve the problem first if this is a
place where you actually want to be and
want to thrive and if you then can't
figure it out or if it does backfire on
you because it because it can get very
political then you start to figure out
what your exit is but again like you
said that exit can be graceful it
doesn't have to be well I'm leaving
because of this and you did that and
blah blah blah if you get an exit
interview and they ask you why you're
leaving give them the facts on why
you're leaving and then leave but it
doesn't have to be
um uh doesn't have to be a moment where
you're giving it to the man you know
what I mean on your way out so when I
did do my exit interview I did inform HR
at that time what my whole experience
was and even she said to me oh my gosh
why didn't you come to us sooner you
know what I mean but for me it was it
just hadn't crossed my mind I hadn't
even thought about it but I did want to
give the feedback on the way out because
I didn't want someone else to have my
experience I wanted to make sure that
even in their marketing and this is
where you know maybe I was stepping over
line but like even in their marketing
stop calling it a program it's not a
program it's a job
right you need people who are ready to
do the job and if they're not ready to
do the job then you need a program that
teaches them that guides them that gives
them a mentor that tells them some of
the stuff that they need to do because
again I came in thinking I'm just going
to be writing some great coverage and
you know possibly get to work with the
writing staffs and blah blah blah I had
no idea all of the rest of it even
existed and how could I being on the
outside even coming from film school
right and so I needed them to have that
feedback so from what I know there was
only one more one more cohort after me
and then the program stopped it had
nothing to do you know with me and what
what happened but I think you know a lot
of programs
um like that no longer exist now and
they kind of ended over the last decade
and even some of the fellowships that we
know really well have been talking about
ending you know because money is being
moved around etc etc but I do think that
it was
um it was necessary because it's very
hard to go from assistant to executive